hi everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina we're here to bring you
the mid-season finale review of arrow
season 2 episode 93 go sort i like to
call this episode the Christmas special
haha a very special greener kali becomes
Ebenezer Scrooge basically and is
visited by the three spirits of
Christmas past I like how they work that
in there here's some dark night spirits
though that experience not Mickey
Mouse's you know the so what you think
about this episode season finale you
know Oh mid-season finale baby I'm sorry
excuse me I've got 13 episodes
throughout it um where do you start off
with an episode like this first of all
there's so much that happens in this
episode it's kind of hard to start but I
mean overall i loved it i thought i was
really great it was a good meat i'm
great mid-season finale um again it's
like every single episode i said this
before they continue to amaze me and
just blow me away with like you know
just so many reveals so many eeckhout
moment yeah you know I loved it right
and I and I'm a little slow sometimes
the comic book references as many people
pointed out so we missed the Solomon
Grundy reference we did but it was
interesting though is that well now we
know this guy I'm assuming he will turn
into Solomon Grundy I mean is he likely
to form with a green gray look but then
but somebody also point out that he
wears the sports masters mask absolutely
no I didn't you know the mass the sports
masters but I Solomon Grundy so he's
that's interesting they're trying to
combine a lot of people but I mean that
was kind of a neat neat neat twist
absolutely read the poem right there and
and going back to what you said about
the whole like Ebenezer Scrooge thing
and stuff I really liked seeing them
really like diving into like the mind of
Oliver cuz I feel like you know we do
but to a certain extent I thought this
was kind of a good way of kind of
showing him breaking down like you know
I mean he can only deal with this for so
long before you start you know like
second-guessing your your your intent
and what you do it on what is that
you're doing what you doing yeah I mean
I think they was good seeing everybody I
guess he is a lady who we know was
killed I'm assuming she is dead dad who
shot in the head so I mean it is comic
book world so who knows but we got to
see you know Deathstroke which is great
that was a pretty cool reveal or do I
mean gee Deathstroke for real not even
yet dream yeah for real awesome we knew
we were gonna see him at some point you
know what I mean but I did not
I did not see that coming that he was
the one that was actually kind of behind
the scenes like brother blood and
basically he's running the show cousin
told himself how you know like you can
easily be replaced right yeah so I mean
he's not even and now we know brother
blood Sebastian Bloods running for mayor
yeah you don't remain so that's a big
reveal it's just so much wow there's so
much to this is almost too much every
bit is throw well all this stuff let's
not forget about you know Roy getting
inject with the meter meter coo coo coo
do mirakuru the meta chlorines so does
that mean that will he become ready or
we go straight to Arsenal eyes neither
is talk CW may be developing a young
justice series which would be really
cool first of all you don't want to be
introduced Android no needles because we
all know how that right wanna be doing
it but again i'm really loving the way
that they're developing roy it seems
like they're moving a little slower with
Roy maybe that's because of the young
justice and I'm fine with that um what
about this isn't it picking I guess I
like the way they handled berries origin
but I kind of would have rather have
seen it in his own show that's what I
thought because the CW exact said that
they were going to give fairy his own
origins or who's gonna get a zone origin
episode not necessarily an arrow so I
wonder are we gonna ricci that scene
again are they gonna show it over again
in the pilot I wonder how the pilot
flash I was just I would imagine that
they would just kind of pick up right
you know where they left off but I just
felt like I love his origin is one of my
favorites yeah and i would i would have
preferred to have seen him spend a
little bit more time on it before he
turned exactly exactly build up to that
amount thats a big one right you know
what I mean not something to be rushed
in like an episode of areas maybe lights
off the train and that happens exactly
there was that one scene when Felicity
comes in and she like what you doing is
I'm just working on something a little
for shadow which I thought was cool but
that would have been enough for me at
least I would be fine with that and then
go into Syria and really build it up but
I mean it was still cool to see me right
you know and other people talked about
to last there's some risk you know we
always like to look at your comments and
respond and see what you guys are
talking about and know some people will
go people said well it was a better
episode last week because Laurel wasn't
involved and it is to Laurel not
anything against the actress no I yeah
just everything to do well that's the
thing like I said can you tell i wanted
i want
like two shows everybody because he told
me share this with me is Mike's idea
sure your Black Canary theory with
Laurel well it'll be interesting could
happen well it gummy knit be interesting
to see if like maybe at some point maybe
you know Sarah does get killed up yeah
you know what I mean maybe she somehow
passes on her training to to Laurel now
I always liked and I don't know maybe
this is just me but when I when I see
her dad I picture was it wild cat yeah
from the Justice Society and stuff and I
always kind of picture him like Trey
because it was an episode last in season
one we kind of seer fighting yeah
ability instead as a chicharrón but
since then you haven't seen anything so
and again this is TV and who knows what
they're really gonna do right with
something like this but like you said I
mentioned this a few weeks back and
stuff I knew like this season at least
you know she's just kind of like a
whatever character she hasn't done much
but if anything I feel like she's kind
of fallen into that whole like you know
dumb girl and you know in distress yeah
like you know she you see her like you
know Connor I don't say she was rushing
to like brother Bloods arms but you can
see as she's getting comfortable when
they start dating that missed that last
week assuming I'm assuming he's probably
just trying to work his way I don't know
if they're dating but maybe just kind of
working his right eye because when he
was for shopping together I mean
something exactly but other than that
like again going back to what I said
earlier with like the ghosts and stuff I
really like the way they play that up I
was a little confused at first when I
saw him fighting Deathstroke because
then he gets into the extra funds like
what happening destroying his let you
know but I like to look at see uh Merlin
yes you know that was a little fun
revealing kind of like basically in the
end you know when he says that you know
I finally got the answer that I was
looking for but there's a reason to why
he's doing what he's doing I think of
anything we're gonna see a different
arrow I mean he's already kind of taking
his first steps into like you know
trying to like not kill people and that
sort of thing but I think now we're
going to maybe see him take you know a
few steps for few more sips for right
you know some looking for two things I
guess let's uh you know or we're kind of
wrap this up sorry maybe looking ahead
because only episode not this is very
interesting point to for a mid-season
finale normally probably 10-11 if we
still have 13 episodes left yeah there's
a lot to go we're not coming back I
think it believes like january fifteenth
or something like that
so looking ahead were looking forward to
we have so much my brother blood
Deathstroke is in Starling city as he is
he is there so we know he's alive which
is great let's not forget race Ross Ra's
al Ghul a show ever you want to say one
say you know will will we see him you
know it's impossible I honestly don't
think we will at least in this season
but obviously you know they're gonna be
you know she bringing in his uh
illegitimate daughter yeah you know any
we strike in Los common thread we still
need to figure out if in fact summer
glau is Talia yeah you know I'm still a
lot my like she's they really i feel
like they've really been done a good job
of teasing her writing too much of her
just like an you know a little like
segments here in there but um yeah
that's something I'm looking forward to
seeing and there's still so much you can
do because like I said every single
episode they're just throwing everything
but the kitchen sink edgy right all the
stuff and I did look ahead to spoil like
you never know how legit this is imdb's
pretty good looked ahead and I'm DB this
it seems any descriptions of any feature
episodes it's only like if you look at
how on IMDb the episode list is only a
few descriptions there is one though
about a billionaire from another city
one do that cuz oh yeah who's that
billionaires there how many days I have
in the DC Universe so will we see Bruce
or maybe maybe we'll hear Bruce's name
at least mention i mean i would happen i
feel like with the the direction that
they're on right now white at least why
not least mention his name right you
know it's interesting one of things that
i was thinking about while watching this
episode I feel like DC is kind of going
kind of following Marvel's footsteps but
in a different way it just seems like
Marvel was quick to kind of build up
their their film franchise and now
they're starting to get the old I've in
the TV or whatnot but I feel like with
DC's doing right now is they're kind of
doing that in the TV world yeah you know
now I don't I kind of hope that they
don't follow Marvel in the sense that I
kind of hope that if they're building a
DC Universe for TV keep it separate from
the film's just so then you don't feel
like you're handcuffed in the condiments
exact look like a batman superman movie
comes down the absa like arrow has to
mention the event said because with
comic books you don't have to do not
locked into a uniform in there is a
universe but there's so much other stuff
going around solutely that hello I mean
so those were you know just some of our
thoughts and there's so much going on
i'm sure you know you guys will call us
out if we we missed anything you know
this what do you think about Solomon
runde we think about the flash reveal
were you happy to see flash I guess you
know get the whole thing with the what's
the what's the call the guys forget the
young well with all is well there's a
particle the particle generator going
and yes I'm happy with that are you
happy with Laurel I mean it's Laurel
doing it for everything about olicity
you know Gotye butter in our love
triangles you gotta mess w shows you got
have got to have a little love triangle
so you know let us know what you think
about that I think about future episodes
and you know as always you can come chat
with us on our website at thank yo calm
let's have a youtube page just YouTube
page right here is called think hero pro
let's find us on twitter if i talk to
michael dennis myself were at think hero
i'm at griffin de and i'm at mr. michael
Alexis we also the facebook page that's
facebook.com slash think hero fans
you'll be sure to give us a like spread
the word subscribe to our page now let
us know what other videos like to see
we're gonna have a little bit of a break
got about a month off so you know we
can't wait to see you guys soon take
care
you